hi jason what's the weather like in
london well martin it's the uk so of
course it's raining outside how about
you how's your weather in california
you know i've had the curtains drawn all
day because i'm recording videos so i
really don't know but today we're
talking about how to coordinate
microservices is it better to have a
central coordinator orchestration or is
it better for control to be distributed
among the services choreography
well with so many things in life it
depends i'd be happy to share what i've
learned from a recent large project
[Music]
thanks for joining me on the show jason
you're a freelance google cloud
architect at 418.dev
yes that's right i'm also a google
developers expert for both firebase and
google cloud platform and i run the
google developer group in milton keynes
which is just outside london
nice i love google developer groups
they're great places for meeting other
developers and learning from each other
now you're helping your parking company
in the uk build their system on top of
google cloud platform right
yes the company collects vehicle
movement and parking permit data from
car parks and motorway services
okay and what is that data used for
they use the data with serverless google
cloud products to provide analytics and
metrics to their customers
the data can also be used for parking
enforcement
oh you mentioned serverless i love that
stuff uh why did they pick serverless
they're using serverless so they can
focus their engineering hours on new
feature development and to minimize the
operations work for their running
systems
got it now there are two ways of
coordinating microservices orchestration
a central coordinator calls all the
microservices in the right order
or choreography microservices send and
receive events and act on them so
control is distributed which one did you
pick for the parking company jason well
each one has particular strengths and
weaknesses so we used both hmm tell me
more about that
well for example when a car enters a
parking lot a camera takes a picture of
their license plate
the picture of the vehicle going in gets
matched with the picture of the vehicle
going out and that match visit then gets
linked to one or more parking permits
that sounds kind of complicated yes and
to make it simpler
we have multiple services each one doing
part of the work
so for example we've got one service
which ingests the data from the cameras
and passes it through the visit matching
service
then another one which ingests the
permit data and matches it with the
visits
got it now how do you coordinate these
services i imagine the camera ingestion
service needs to let the matching
service know that a vehicle has entered
or exited but we use orchestration where
a central controller
calls a series of services in a pipeline
and returns a result okay that sounds
pretty straightforward it's nice to have
control of the business logic in one
place right yes but sometimes that isn't
optimal
we are using a nosql document database
that is optimized for reads so we can
sometimes need to denormalize data
for example an administrator may update
the expiry date for a whole group of
parking permits
if the expiry date has been extended
a visit that was beyond the expiry date
may now be within it so the driver
shouldn't have to pay a parking penalty
charge
everyone hates paying parking penalties
especially if their permit was just
extended
now how do you prevent that
when the permit group is updated
we trigger updates of all the permits in
that group
this in turn means that we have to match
the permits against the visits again
okay but why can't you use a central
coordinator for this if we only want to
change the expiry date of one permit
we don't need to update any other
permits we only need to trigger the
visit matching again
a central coordinator will become very
complex if it should be able to handle
both updates to many permits
and updates just to individual permits
ah i see so if you don't use
orchestration what do you use instead
then we use the other method
choreography where each service receives
messages
takes action on those messages and sends
new messages to the other services
so in what situations do you pick
orchestration and when do you pick
choreography instead
when the process is always the same
orchestration shines
for example when a car enters we always
save the raw camera data
the data is transformed from each
camera's manufacturer's proprietary
format to our standard data format
and then we extract the images from that
and save them into google cloud storage
finally we send the event data to cloud
pub sub for processing further down the
pipeline
that makes sense and when do you use
choreography when we have services which
may form part of a workflow but may also
be triggered individually
a good example is the permit group
scenario we talked about earlier
got it now it sounds like choreography
is based on having many triggers isn't
it messy to have lots of triggers all
over the system how do you manage that
complexity if you're using cloud
functions or cloud run services directly
in google cloud
it's really essential to maintain good
documentation and use a tool like
deployment manager or terraform to
deploy them
however if you're using the firebase
suite it's much easier to develop
test and deploy your cloud functions
there's even a great local emulator
okay does that mean that you prefer to
use cloud functions for firebase all the
time cloud functions for firebase only
support node.js and typescript which is
great for web developers but if your
team uses another language such as go or
python it may not be such a great fit
got it and which google products do you
recommend for orchestration and for
choreography respectively
for orchestration workflows is a great
product for designing orchestration
pipelines
workflows can be triggered by other
services such as cloud functions cloud
run or cloud scheduler
for choreography you can use event arc
to trigger individual cloud run or cloud
function services based on individual
events
however there are some services like
cloud firestore and cloud storage which
can trigger cloud functions directly
without event arc whenever an event
happens
okay and to recap when would you
recommend using orchestration versus a
choreography architecture
if you're developing a traditional
n-tier system on google cloud it's
probably best to use the orchestration
model
however if you're building a user
interface focused application with
something like the firebase suite
this is where choreography works really
well however
there may be times that you need to
create a hybrid app
in which case you can leverage the best
of both worlds
the best of both worlds i like that
thank you for joining me and sharing
your real world experience jason happy
to do it and thank you everyone for
watching if you have any questions for
jason or me add a comment below
also let me know if there are other
serverless topics you'd like to see in
future episodes bye for now
[Music]